have been hard to resist those
Temptations with girls throwing
themselves at you all the time we don't
necessarily like to talk about the
Purity Rings it is a crazy world we're
living in and and we're just having fun
doing what we're doing you guys see
Miley's picture
[Applause]
thank you before the Purity rings and
the Miley Cyrus fling catch this
again E.T first met Nick Jonas in 2006
after he hit the Disney scene with his
brothers
Jonas Brothers I'm Kevin I'm Nick hey
everybody I'm Joe who's the oldest I am
you're the oldest and how old are you
I'm 20. you're twenty eighteen eighteen
fifteen our fans are amazing they are
crazy they'll Run next to our buses
every time we leave the venues Nick's
entrance into Showbiz didn't start with
the band it was on Broadway
[Music]
Phantom Shadows on the floor
singing show tunes in Les Mis and Beauty
and the Beast it started out with
Nicholas being having um being on
Broadway and then doing a song and
getting signed to a record label and
then all three of us just writing a song
together and someone hearing it and
reading like oh let's turn this into a
brother's house
can we talk about Nick's glow up though
from Camp Rock to totally cut
[Music]
but we know it all goes down in the DMS
in 2017 Nick slid in Priyanka chopras
and just like that he was off the market
I'm a sucker for you I'm very happy yeah
I would say that I'm the happiest I've
ever been and after their 2018 wedding
Nick is a zaddy welcoming his first
child via surrogate with Priyanka in
January the hell's fatherhood been for
you it is certainly life-changing she's
uh she's amazing
um brings me a lot of joy
[Applause]
I don't know how this could get much
better
[Music]